would you say that i'm a minimalist
i'm curious it depends i would say no
because of the car but this is an
interesting philosophy because
you can afford it um like that's
and every guy needs a hobby every guy
needs a vice you can't just be living in
a hut
and not having some kind of uh a hobby
uh if people are like borrowing money
and and trying to but you're not trying
to put up the facade we talked about
your fancy cars and everything before
that's that's your passion you enjoy it
you actually go out and drive it you're
not doing it to impress anybody you just
like
having fancy cars but if i can buy a car
that costs four times as much
and i settle on something that costs
less but still delivers the experience
that i'm looking for
i feel like that makes me a minimalist
can i can i get a hurrah or something
you get a hurrah yeah but like it i
would say you should rent
you see like go rent it for a week and
then and then get another car
speaking of renting talk about the
picture of you in front of that ferrari
on the
thumbnail because you know i had to
create the event i'm like aaron wants to
talk about minimum like aaron cleary
at google images and it's like in the
top row it's like there's a picture of
you in front of a ferrari and it talks
i'm like that's the one that we're going
to use
yes yes uh jack napier oh you a
minimalist it's like okay one i didn't
own the ferrari i rented it it was
it was my girlfriend's 40th birthday she
always wanted to drive a ferrari
and then i rented it i think we rented
it for three days and what was funny is
because
i gave a buddy of mine my truck the old
one that you you are surprised still
drives around so
i lent it to a buddy and we took the
ferrari and so i'm like
you still have to run errands so i'm
like delivering pizzas i put pizza in
the ferrari and i'm getting groceries in
the ferrari
like this is kind of weird uh but that
was that was a short-term rental but
i got to experience it yeah and and now
i know i never want to drive a ferrari
ever again because they're loud and
clunky
didn't like it nope very loud very you
think it's always breaking down it's
like nah that's just the engine doing
its thing
so no it's yeah it's loud it makes a lot
of uh
noises very loud noises you know as we
like to say
you